with Denver if you follow Bucks
basketball you know how difficult it has
been on the road for the Bucks against
the Nuggets they have won just eight
times in their entire history down I
said at Combe bow into the post knock
the way or at least it got away who
might have lost it went to Yogesh J
point mate right through the bottom will
punch if he runs into the break into the
post
Martin leaves it for yo kids gets it
back he got behind at under Bledsoe for
an easy basket with a pass to the
pattern nope it's the rebound and in
among all of the things he'd done that
gets now hand off the Harris and his
jumper is what he'd have done with that
a while ago has it off the man out
Wilson Chandler [ __ ] nicely by Tony
Snell Jochen for three from the top
Nicole Bitchie that off the miss
for 34 remaining in the second quarter
Yogesh for unanswered points ocean
threes the Bucs have allowed under joke
frontage rain and 12 there's another one
that's 12 put them through that if
you're gonna wear this ball did so
hopefully they don't start missing and
the defense will start even getting
better not like that and in Gomez inside
the restricted area really challenged
Morgan's with the hands up defense that
we've talked about it Yogesh works into
the paint to score nikola yogic you can
transition ganas has 21 the Bucks have
eight fast-break points just one fewer
than Denver and the three is to get back
completely on this Denver team 81 76 and
the Bucks have been playing really well
better be better offense
dawn-marie backs out yogurts for three
see Jim I accept
there's a two-man game going
[Music]
yup it's back to Jamal Murray portrayed
what a shot